I mean there's several methods how you
can do Road inspection citizens sending
out its inspectors or having specialized
vehicles they have special sensors
looking at the road the problem is it's
very expensive so these these three
things the standard methods right now so
what we developed is using smart cameras
in vehicles to detect damage so we mount
this in the windshield you can put this
on any vehicle you want you know my
vision is always to put it on garbage
trucks because garbage trucks go through
every neighborhood once a week so you
could inspect the whole city once a week
this data then is downloaded through
Wi-Fi through cloud onto our computers
then we look at these images and analyze
and find out how many cracks we can see
in those images so here you see a map a
street map of Pittsburgh and all these
little dots are the images which we
collected the color of these dots
indicate the condition of the road very
red one you see that here are in this
image are cracks in comparison here is a
green one a road which has been recently
paid so in the same way that we can
detect cracks we cannot detect winter
road conditions we did do a test put the
same system on snow plows while it's
plowing we look outside to see if the
road if it's just wet or if they're
slush or if there's snow so it is in
general for weather in infrastructure
detection so eventually we want to do
any infrastructure you can see in in
those images what we've done so far is
the roads cracks on the roads and the
traffic signs and we have started to
look at street lamps at the lane
markings it's a very inexpensive very
efficient way to inspect your
infrastructure
you